why would you need to go to a club with
just your girls you can say that your
partner is your best friend my best
friend I want to do everything if I go
to the store I'm like yo come tag along
with me because they're not accepting
you for who you are and I think it does
work both ways with women women are
usually going to the club by themselves
and that's what I was doing in that
relationship as I was going out with my
friends because I could act like myself
and he always tried to repress who I was
and I was like crazy girl and like
having fun and doing whatever I wanted
and he would always it's pronounced for
it cool I think that's why people go out
separately because they want to be
themselves without being judged do
people expect there to be no changes or
sacrifices and relationships anymore
like I like going out with my friends
and I like drinking and just flirting
with a lot of guys what because I'm in a
relationship I don't get to do that
anymore yes yes
by relation
ship
ing my authentic well that's a bad self